now from painting the stars to painting
among them well that's the ambition of
young artist max denison pender he hopes
to join japanese billionaire yosako
mazawa's mission around the moon
in 2023 and paint in space mr
zawa has invited eight members of the
public to join him for a trip
around the moon on elon musk's space x
flight in two years time
and max is hoping to be one of them let
us join
him now good afternoon one earth do you
want to leave terra firma
afternoon nick thank you for having me
um so it's been my ambition
since i can remember uh when i was young
i had stars
all over my bedroom um and being being a
painter since
um since i can remember so the idea to
say paint and space that you know you
you're in this
nothingness like like no no artist has
ever been there
and one of my favorite artists like um
turner he used to tie himself to the
master of a boat to see the storm or i
can imagine if he was in
our time today he would jump at the
opportunity and i just can't miss
the opportunity so i am saying to you
sacrifice hour
take me to space what do you think it's
going to be like
um i think it's going to be something
out of this world i mean
the perspective that only you know a
very small handful of people on this
earth have ever witnessed
to then be translated by my paintbrush
um you know it's an experience that that
will will change my mind
and change my you know my sort of
imagination my concept of the world
forever
uh and and i think my original ambition
was to be the first artist
on the moon and so i thought this is the
best way to be most qualified to yell
so yeah have you put your application
form in
i have i have and um i started my
campaign
a week before he announced he wanted to
let all creatives come on come on board
so
he's now released a uh sign up so all
creatives can come
and i'm saying that i need to be that
artist he takes
and one of the biggest things that drew
me to it
was the fact that he wants to uh use
this
gig to promote world peace and for me
that means a lot
and i thought you know i i'm the man i
i've
dedicated my whole life to my painting
i'm here seven days a week
and if anyone's going to be on that
bloody rock it's going to be me
well so we uh yeah i know you're excited
but we uh
maybe a step too far slightly with that
word so let's uh yes
don't worry um now i want to ask you
what's been the reaction from people to
your
aspiration maybe perhaps tell me what
your mum thought
um so i've i've been receiving quite a
lot of support really
piers morgan very kindly got behind me
and shared the video
uh a few influences um and really
i think people appreciate uh dream big
you know i think um
so many people aren't willing to dare
dream big
and for me whether or not this campaign
gets his attention
um i hope it does but in the end of the
day i
was told all of my life that being an
artist was a bad idea
uh you can't make a living out of it and
i've i've sort of proved everyone wrong
so
i'm all about telling everyone to chase
their dreams and so
if this is a mess that i can get across
by doing this that's a win for me
and your mom in particular what has
family had to say
uh sorry they're they're all behind it i
mean my mum was uh
they they are like okay max can you
leave some paintings with us
in case the uh the the trail in case
it's a one-way ticket
[Music]
as it is you know you've got a life is
sure i could go and get a coffee from a
more cafe
and and get hit by bus you know so
that's just how life is and you can't
i don't want to have any regrets and um
and i'm truly following all
spacex's progress i truly think elon
musk
is the man for the job and he will do
this you know he's landing a rocket the
same size as big ben
and it landed last time and it
unfortunately blew up about five minutes
after it landed but
you know next time around i think it's
gonna land right well
good luck let us know how you get on but
for now max dennis and pender thanks a
lot
all the best thank you